mark
chris congratulations the strength of
your weapons
has carried you into the final round of
this competition now we're sending you
back to your home fortress to recreate
an iconic weapon from history
that weapon is
the tabar shish park
good luck bladesmiths we'll see you in
five days
good luck
i have to build this tabar shisbar
i have never made a bludgeoning weapon
today
i'm gonna work on the shaft of this
weapon i have material but
i don't think it's quite tough enough so
i'm getting another one inside of
it to make sure that it can stand any
challenge that they give me
a little bit heavier but i think the
judges are up to that challenge
i've forged the handle areas into my
shaft
the whole shaft is as straight as i can
make it so we'll get ready to heat treat
this
i've never quenched a hollow tube before
kids don't try this at home
[Music]
that was exciting it's like mount
vesuvius exploding
it's kind of fun to watch but a little
bit scary too
there is our hardened tube of 1084
steel i got a lot of work done but i've
got a lot of work still ahead of me
i got all the forging done everything
forged into rough shape
the first step today is get the parts of
the mace
cut to shape so far so good
the five pieces have to be consistent so
when you look at that mace
everything's perfect all in a row
i'm feeling pretty good i'm ahead of
schedule
finally done shaping now it's time to
heat treat
what could go wrong all the work so far
is coming down to this step
if i don't get this right the rest of
the time will have been for nothing
really
okay axe heads going in
i got the heat treating done i couldn't
be happier
i feel like i'm a bit ahead of my game
yesterday i forged out my tabar axe as
well as the flanges
today i need to do all my heat treating
and that's really important grab my wire
and do all these together and then do
the axe because i want to be a little
more careful with it
i need to focus on not making mistakes
without the heat treat
i don't have a weapon despite all the
work i've done
nothing matters until this thing comes
out of that oil looking happy
it's an axe i'm feeling really good i
got my flanges heat treated i got the
axe heat treated
and tomorrow i can work on assembly
i will be spending a lot of time on the
grinder today it's time to start
grinding things to shake
so we're cruising downhill from here
yeah for three days i was thinking
everything is going
too darn smooth something's gonna happen
and it did
i found two cracks right now i'm looking
at two options
i can try and make this one work or
start over make a new one
i may be able to save this blade i'm
gonna cut this out right like this
i could cut around the first crack and
grind out
the one top i'm not taking any chances
with this
i don't want to have it fail on me so
i'm gonna give this thing the toughest
test that i could give it
i think it'll be good bladesmiths
the tabar shishbar is one weapon with
multiple personalities
to see what kind of lethal damage your
weapon will do i will take you to bar
shush bart
and use both ends to deliver killing
blows on this ballistics dummy
mark you up first you ready mm-hmm let's
see it
[Music]
omar it is sharp that
chopped right into the chest cavity
breaking a bone
this axe dug in and gutted him
your mace definitely will crush
you can see the breaking bones inside
your weapon will kill thank you
chris you ready i am
[Music]
oh my gosh into the lung into the heart
your mace definitely penetrated through
the skull
bones are broken i don't think it's
going to end well
your weapon is heavy and i'm not a fan
of heavy weapons
only because you have to carry it to
battle but overall
it will kill thank you all right
gentlemen this is the sharpness test
the two bar only has one sharp area
which is the axe head
so i'll strike into this side of beef
six times with each of your axes
mark you up first are you ready for this
[Music]
your weapon's nice and light for a
weapon that looks as heavy as this
is you can see that this just went right
through
the ribs this is definitely a cutter
good job thank you chris you ready
let's do it
[Music]
well right off the weight difference
i mean this thing hits like a ton these
hooks
tear meat coming out the back way your
edge
there's no damage that i can feel
it's heavy but uh it does a hell of a
lot of damage
nicely done thank you all right
gentlemen this is the strength test
now to test the strength and durability
of your tabar shish bars
i'll be using all parts of it to strike
this suit of armor
mark you're up you ready yes i am let's
see it
[Music]
edge is still perfect no chips no
rolling
the hammer gave that armor a nice dent
didn't take any damage
mace is fine the guy inside there was
not happy
all right chris you ready for this don't
hold back i'm not gonna
[Music]
[Music]
this is a heavy weapon yeah i mean i can
control it
but i don't have any rebound
and you got just the smallest bit of
edge
deformation here other than that
mace is a devastator you made a
beautiful piece
thank you i hope the judges appreciate
the devastation my weapon's capable of
bringing
it's hard to say who's gonna win
bladesmiths the judge's deliberation is
complete
and there can only be one forged and
fire champion
and that champion is
[Music]
mark congratulations you are the fortune
fire champion
thank you good job buddy thanks
chris your blade did not make the cut
david baker will explain
chris doug and i both agree that the
extreme weight of your weapon
made it difficult to control and frankly
i'm still feeling it in my arm
that combined with that minor edge
damage you took in the strength test
those the reasons we're letting you go
understood
chris it's that time please surrender
your weapons
i think i put up the best i was capable
of in the time that i was given
see everybody congratulations mark did
good work and his was just a little bit
[Music]
better
mark congratulations you are the fortune
fire champion and will be receiving a
check for 10 000
good job
how do you feel right now i feel great
chris
a hell of an opponent i'm glad it went
to the very end i wanted to see a real
competition
mark please present your weapon to the
judges and shake our hands
i won i am the champion
unbelievable i just won ten thousand
dollars
my wife and i we made a deal she gets
nine thousand
and i get a thousand so congratulations
dear
you